a little bit about the story of this
third one and what do you want fans to
know cool um well for John wick chapter
three we call it para bellum which is a
Latin phrase for our derive from see
this packet para bellum if you want
peace prepare for war we thought it was
a cool way to to break into the John
with chapters as we call them if you
watched John with one to two they almost
take off where the other one ends and
three takes place pretty much where
number two ends so it's another chapter
in it we're picking John wake up right
where he left off so there's a bounty on
his head all the all the assassins in
the Camorra and the what we call the
high table which is their overall ruling
organization all want John dead he's
done something wrong he's killed
somebody in the Continental tale which
is breaking the rules so there's that
aspect where John's running from
breaking the rules and there's an aspect
that all the freelance guys want dead
for 14 million bucks and in order to do
that John has to seek not only
absolution for himself but forgiveness
from again the high table to somehow get
him out of the the hot spot that he's
now in we are in the editing room right
now you've been living and breathing in
this room for this is this little
rectangular box is our world these two
screens and what's left of my brain yes
and the hallway of editors sound mixers
visual effects and music composers Jim
where are you in the Edit with the
release date coming may 17th May 17th
coming up quick we've been through our
assembly our director's cut our first
test screening cut and every time you
know we're shaving you down trying to
get to the heart of the story and dial
and the action sequences so sort of
pacing both story wise and action wise I
think we've probably got if there's no
kind of it's 20% more movie than number
two so the script was a little bit
thicker there's more characters in this
one and we've upped the action I think
by at least three sequences which means
the body count is substantially higher
so we're trying to find a nice pacing
for all that what is the when you have a
movie coming up
17 there's obviously a due date to the
studio where it's the drop the picture
lock yeah so what day do you have to
deliver them
uh it's depending on how a different
studio releases or where the foreign
market is or how their release in
theaters is kind of dependence how much
leeway we have I have about five weeks
left before I have to actually picture
lock or visually lock the movie and then
VFX sound and music all we can still
keep adding and playing with that so but
the actual visuals of the movie are
gonna be launched within five weeks five
to six weeks
sure um obviously people love seeing
Keanu kick-ass and John wick is about
their incredible kicking ass down line
right like it's it's um phenomenal
action set-pieces um what can you tease
in terms of how many action set-pieces
are in this film and the way you up the
ante compared to the first two um again
like the overall vibe of how like myself
my part I'm Dave Leitch kind of did the
the first John wick was okay well we
didn't have a lot of money on the first
one so we tried to keep it like look
we're gonna do this a little bit more
organic a little bit more old-school
stunts in action wise where you know no
wire work minimal stunt doubles try to
contain it the things we like cars
motorcycles fights Falls flips things
that can be organically done with our
cast without big VFX cost or big big
action sequence cost of collapsing
buildings and earthquakes and all that
so when we started design the sequence
there's a lot of fights and the gun food
that you see and the reason we do all
the judo and jujitsu and and contact or
grappling arts because you don't have to
do a lot of reverses with punches hits
misses there's not a lot of high kicking
or big aerial stuff that uh that some of
the bigger movies will do because it
takes time and stunt doubles and digi
doubles and we want to keep it all look
we're gonna train Keanu to the best of
our ability or anybody in our cast for
that matter to the best of the ability
with the time we have modify the action
choreography or the martial art aspect
of it to what we think is achievable and
the design all the sequences around that
so we've had now three movies with Keanu
he's been training pretty much the whole
time so his martial art choreography his
punches kicks flips Falls fights are
better his weapon based stuff so like
firearms
knives are better he's a professional
motorcycle rider so he used a little of
that we kind of leading into what
counters were really good at and then I
think we have depending how you cut up
like eight or nine action sequences that
are true sequences or fight scenes and
in each one we try to do a little bit of
a different gag to it like he may be
empty hands this may be more firearms
this may be more let's call it a canine
aspect one may be above or below water
one may be on motorcycles and then the
set pieces we change so every vibe
should be a little bit different so it's
more of a an eclectic assortment of
action sequences rather than just a
fight if I had if I had a fight a fight
if that makes any sense completely one
of the things I really love about the
films is that you do have these long
shots which show that it's Keano
how does that continue in this film and
do you have those shots with Halle and
yeah um again it's just that I mean
everything is good I mean what every
action movie every director every editor
every action choreographer hazzard vibe
whether it's the borns with a little bit
more shaky and fast editing or Marvel
which is bigger and condensed and in and
out in and out or if it's like John wick
when you try to do longer takes like I
certainly don't try to do one take
wonders this long one-shot thing I just
believe in order to suck you into the
movie rather than cutting cutting
cutting cutting and seeing you know what
is obviously a stunt double or a digi
double or trying to hide things I'd
rather show things off at the sacrifice
of trying to be fast and interject
pacing if you have a good cast member
like Keanu that can do the choreography
has a good memory and can perform at a
level I'd rather you see that and I
think that vests you more into the
character of John wick Keano is John key
Annika do you believe oh well John wick
can do it because camera can do it like
you're seeing an actual human do a bunch
of cool moves time it right shoot the
gun do the reloads do the cool flip do
the shoulder I'll come back oh my god
here comes a dog if I hold in longer
takes I think that sucks the audience
more into the action a little bit rather
than just trying to infuse something
that wasn't there in the rehearsal like
hopefully if people saw rehearsal tapes
or our you know our previous tapes or
pre-visualization tapes that the stunt
guys do for us to see how they're doing
you should watch those we go wow holy
[ __ ] those look really good too you know
so I'm just recording what's already
been rehearsed that's great if you watch
a rehearsal tape and you're bored
your mind then you got to go into
problem-solving like oh yeah oh this
isn't how we gonna do that okay let's
shoot really tight and shake it out
I think that's become that styles become
more about hiding things and infusing
energy action and pacing into something
that didn't have in the first place we
just said well that's kind of a penny
ass Chuck that let's try to make it
great from beginning and then leave it
up to me to [ __ ] it up now if I if I
screwed up but at least it's there to
begin with and I think that's what the
longer takes or the more involved
choreography is and again John wick is a
it's a it's a mana take fantasy kind of
adventure thing so rather than swords of
knights of the round table we use
pistols or rifles or whatever it is and
we want the audience know we're having
fun but we also see like look cool
people that put time in and energy and
actually practice can do cool things and
that's kind of what the John wick vibe
is with whether it's Hallie and yes we
do I think some of the most impressive
shots or takes are with Halle Berry and
Keanu and the dogs all interlinking into
into a sequence cannot wait definitely
want to know about the in the editing
room itself ultimately the final rewrite
what have you learned while in the
editing room and you mentioned you had a
longer script and everything sim was
your first cut you look a lot longer
like what you have been like um again
not gonna lie to you like this is my
third time as a director as an action
director I have a good sense of pacing
of how many days to shoot what and what
that comes like inhibitory gonna pacing
when you step into the director chair
it's not just about hurrying up and
duration of film to hurry up and get in
how a 90-minute film or a 90-minute film
or an hour and a half film it's about
how to give the audience a break and
find that natural pacing of okay let's
have some really fun let's have a good
laugh let's have some dramatic let's
let's find the ebb and flow of the film
so John wick was what I would call more
of a 2-out kind of thing people kill dog
John ghost kills everybody that's you're
on the ride the character arts gonna be
a little a little shallow out you know
we know that we want to have fun with it
in Parabellum it's a lot more there's
two storylines going on with Ian McShane
and Keanu what's going on New York
what's going on with John wick as we
follow his character so as a director
the page
a little bit different it's more of a
three-act film as opposed to the other
two or more to act films so I guess at
at Orly it comes down to okay
with a longer script you can put
everything that you've shot into it and
that becomes about two hours and 46
minutes which is a little too long and a
lot of it is repetitive and a lot of it
kind of it's almost too much so
sometimes you can bring things out by
subtracting things but I really
highlighting some thumb attic moments
and what the story is really about and
how to get the two story points quicker
and when you get into editorial you
learn very quickly how to reduce or like
they say what a good sculpting is chip
away the own essential x' so you may
have something that reads very well but
visually it may be more of a speed bump
than an enhancement and just editorials
the experimentation the painful creative
experimentation of removing what gets in
the way of something great you mentioned
that you did a test screening recently
touch screens can sometimes really
impact the film because you learn what
they believe you know so what did you
learn from any screenings have you know
done shine so you got something I think
when you're in the test screening for
those that don't know what it is they
actively recruit and they can recruit
people that know what the film is or
they can do a blind recruit which you
don't know and you get surprised and you
get a mixed bag of audience members that
either our action fans are not action
fans
either way it's I look at it as two
stages
there's the during the show hearing the
audience reacting with them being and
then feeling the vibe when people are
bored excited and then there's the after
when they have to fill out the forms I I
love like a good example allergies like
I love the original Highlander if you go
watch it or like there's something about
the violent took but if I were to sit
down and break it down on piece of paper
it's good Romans I think I've ever seen
the point is if I'm watching it I'm
gonna cheer and when I write it down and
think about while the editing was a
great delight it doesn't really hold up
in time but so that you have to take
both with both what I'm saying is I look
at the the audience reaction when I'm
sitting in a crowd of 500 people and
people laugh and people cheer those are
honest reactions you don't have to think
about it they just happen that's one
very important spot
okay we're hitting our beats it's good
and then you go into the second phase
which is okay they're writing down
where were you confused what did you not
get what did you understand how much did
you like each person that you got to
take a look a little grain of salt and
figure out what kind of fans you're
dealing with and how not to overthink a
note but also characterized by that
pacing is always a really true now like
you know there's a lot of countries that
wake what's the best thing you like
about John wake three we love the action
we love the option okay well what's the
best well there's just a lot of action a
lot action okay so you're best known
you're worse know the same thing it's a
tricky one to handle you love your
action and we want you to change it but
if you change it we may hate it okay so
you'll love all the exo best
action-packed movie ever seen there's
too much okay what you want to cut we
don't know good luck and that is a
director saying I've never heard that
from any director as a note you loved
the action and there's too much I've
gotten on all three John weeks that's
crazy
we love the head shots but a story
cutting shoes guys enhance blister you
don't see with the headshots that they
like the same reason you love it soon as
it hit us the same way as you hated same
region love us that's the trick of it so
you okay do you do you d go with the
John Wood fans like yeah or do you try
to trim so that somewhere that's not an
action movie fan just heard some get
through we try to do real choreography
like anybody that does Aikido I get you
- gia - judo Samba we'll watch they go
holy [ __ ] that you really learn that
stuff anybody that knows anything about
tactical firearm work whoa look at it go
oh my god he's doing the real deal
if you're not familiar with those
disciplines you'd be like oh I just it's
all the same he's shooting guys in the
head 20 pound okay yes we do it for both
sides we try to get the energy of the
humor for all of our audience but we
also try to put in specifics that if you
are into genre stuff if you Nakuru saw
if you're in a Sergio Leone if you like
spaghetti westerns you've got kung fu
movies you're gonna see a lot of
references in here that the generic fan
would not get if you're a martial art
enthusiast or your you know firearm
enthusiasts or your motorcycle disease
or sword enthusiast you're going to get
a lot more out of this and than most and
you know coming from let's just say a
very nerdy upbringing I like throwing
that stuff in there and I like throwing
those in there and that's why we kind of
overdo it a little bit just to kind of
throw a little nod to all the people out
there
love the same kind of stuff we love
otherwise we wouldn't made the movie in
the first place I got two last questions
who are you
we saw a picture a long time ago about
Keanu on the horse and I've been waiting
- I'm very I'm really anticipating this
scene what can you tease about Keano on
a horse in New York City I'll start with
that why again
like it just rift I love Sergio Leone I
am a big fan of old-school westerns and
especially the Leone westerns so you
know I spent so much time in New York
trying to come up with okay for people
that don't know a lot of times the
writer can write a scene happens in
warehouse and a fight scene a warehouse
to us at this stage is very boring so we
try to find set pieces for the action
first like okay we want to do it in a
glass house we want to do in a mirror
and we want to do it in a waterfall and
then design the action around a cool set
piece to give an aesthetic to it and we
wanted to do a bit of a chase but we've
done car chases and we've done
motorcycle chases and we do bow chases
me that airplane is for like you know
horses and we know can I riffle oh okay
okay I mean it may can I make a list of
everything he could do at the beginning
and he had you know done a lot of riding
back in the day and he had done 47 Ronin
which was required to do a lot of riding
and like you sure you're good he's like
I got a horse all day and so we took him
to the stables new house really yeah
yeah pretty good you can ride a horse
we're like okay we have you ran away
through New York anyway come again
well I had done a preliminary Scout
there and we went through Central Park
and it was freezing cold out and there
was all the carriages by Central Park
and horses and we had this random
questions like I want to really put
these guys so we asked one of the the
carriage drivers like we're DS and
literally two blocks off Central Park
little went like right in Manhattan of
these stables and you it would look like
a regular five-story building we just
stables in we're like John wick runs
into a stable we got it horses we're
doing a water sequence galley you're
riding you're gonna go underneath the
elevated train in Brooklyn we're riding
a horse he's like really it's like yeah
you gonna do some Sergio Leone [ __ ]
you're gonna ride a horse and you use a
revolver done that's crazy
I had no idea that that horse stables
like that right there
we didn't either now we just and it was
like okay so we're like okay that's
different about New York and only in New
York
I [ __ ] love New York for action
it's awesome I that's amazing my last